there's a new ps4 update out now and if  you've downloaded it you know it doesn't  do a whole lot still I'm Tony and this  is your obligatory GameSpot news update  ps4 update 5.55 is mandatory and  according to the patch notes it quote  improved system performance yep that's  it I guess they can't all be as  substantial as Marches 5.50 update it  asks for that long-awaited ability to  change your PSN name I guess you'll just  have to keep waiting maybe Sony will say  something at e3 speaking of which  Sony's e3 press conference is set for  Monday June 11th at 6 p.m. pacific 9  p.m. Eastern or 2:00 a.m. June 12th in  the UK and it will focus on four big  games death stranding ghosts of Tsushima  The Last of Us part two and spider-man  we discussed that lineup when it was  first announced on our live news show  GameSpot daily you can watch that every  weekday at 11 a.m. Pacific  [Music]